and so today the first speaker is
henry yuan from columbia university go
ahead henry
all right thanks ignacio uh hi everyone
um
uh so um
so this is a joint work with my student
greg rosenthal
um who's uh on this call i think and um
yeah so today i'll be uh talking about
interactive proofs for
um uh performing uh
truly quantum tasks in this case um
synthesizing quantum states
uh and unitaries um and probably due to
time i won't have a chance to talk about
synthesizing unitaries but i'll just
focus on the task of synthesizing
quantum states
so let's get into it
so here's the the motivating tasks that
i want to think about so suppose you're
given a succinct description
of an n qubit quantum circuit c that has
exponentially many
uh gates so i think a useful example to
keep in mind is imagine that
the circuit c implements say the the
time evolution of some local hamiltonian
for an exponential uh long amount of
time
okay and your goal is to synthesize
uh the final state of this uh the
circuit
um on input say the all zero state
so um you know this is a very very long
circuit and so we expect that
the state psi that's the result of this
circuit to be very complicated and you
want to get your hands
on this state
so i call this task state synthesis
just your state synthesis in general
refers to you know you're given some
succinct description of a state and you
want to
prepare the state in this case the
obvious solution is well you can just
run the circuit you spend
an exponential amount of time using
polynomial
amount of space to construct the state
and
we don't expect to be able to synthesize
this state
in polynomial time unless p space
is contained in bqp which we we don't
expect
um so so you know this is seems like a
difficult task
um but what if now uh you can interact
with an all-powerful approver
can you then uh somehow shortcuts this
long process to efficiently construct
the state
and have it in your hands
so here's the model that i want to
consider
um you know we have uh you know some
quantum polynomial time verifier uh
interacting with some all-powerful
quantum prover
the this interaction can be quantum
and we think of this prover as you know
it can do anything it likes it can
compute
you know very difficult problems prepare
difficult states
we just don't trust approver so the goal
here
is by interacting with this untrusted
approver we want to
verifiably synthesize this complicated
state
psi in polynomial time
so the question is is can we do this
so let me be a little more precise by
what we mean by an interactive protocol
to synthesize a state
so i'm going to call say that an
interactive state synthesis protocol
for the state psi is an interactive
protocol that satisfies
completeness and soundness property the
completeness
property is that there is some uh prover
strategy
called the the honest prover strategy
such that the verifier will accept
with some probability uh greater than c
so c
is the completeness parameter um in this
talk you can think of c
as being one so if the
is being honest it will always be
accepted
and the output of the protocol so the
verifier is going to output some quantum
state
and this output should be close to the
desired
target state psi
the soundness property is that for all
prover strategies no matter what the
prover does
if uh the verifier accepts with some
probability greater than s
so s is a soundness parameter think of
it as some number like
uh say a half or uh one percent or
something like that
um then we want that the output state
conditioned on accepting
the verifier accepting is going to be
close to the target state
so if the verifier accepts then it
should have some
good confidence that the state it has in
its hands is really this target state
psi
so that's what i mean by an interactive
state synthesis protocol
okay so the goal is we want to cons you
know construct such a protocol for for
the state psi
now
you know maybe some of you might might
be wondering well how does this relate
to
a famous result about quantum
interactive proof systems
um there's this theorem qip equals
pspace which is by jane
g ubba da and watrus
now doesn't this imply that there's an
interactive proof for
for solving this problem you know after
all this state
psi is the result of a quantum
polynomial space
computation that takes exponential time
but we also have this uh this result by
watrus that quantum polynomial space
is equal to classical polynomial space
so so therefore doesn't
q p equals p space implies something
about
our ability to solve the state synthesis
task
well this this starts to run into this
distinction between
[Music]
quantum tasks and let's say classical
computational tasks
or another way to put it is really this
is coming to the difference between
search and decision problems in the
quantum world
so the theorem qip equals p space is a
result about decision problems
um the verifier uh in in this setting uh
it wants to verify whether some input x
is in some language l and
that's just a decision problem it has a
yes or no answer
state synthesis on the other hand can
really be thought of as a
in some sense a quantum search problem
right at the end of the protocol the
verifier
doesn't just want to have a yes or no
answer but it wants to have in its hands
an entire n qubit state
and um you know the thing is in the
quantum setting the relationship between
search and decision problems is much
more mysterious
so to give an example
uh in classical complexity theory
search problems and decision problems
are uh often
you know treated interchangeably like
they have the same complexity
so for example you know if if you have
the ability to efficiently decide
three set then you can also use that uh
to efficiently find satisfying
assignments
but um it's unknown whether this search
to decision
reduction uh extends to the quantum
setting so for example
it's unknown that you know suppose that
um
qma were equal to bqp we don't think
this is true but
imagine uh that were the case does this
imply that
um you can find ground states of local
hamiltonians in polynomial time
we don't know at least i don't know of
a way to do that um and in fact
i have some some evidence in the form of
an oracle result
um that that kind of uh
gives you know some evidence that
there's no efficient search to decision
reduction
um for qma relative relative to the
oracle
so the you know at least in the case of
qma versus np there seems to be a
difference between whether you can
reduce search to decision
now coming to back to our task of
interactive state synthesis if we think
about the
classical analog of this problem you
know i'll call this classical
interactive state synthesis
um this has a pretty straightforward
solution again sort of just
using some kind of search to decision
reduction
so here let's say the goal is you're
given a
a polynomial space classical turing
machine
m and you want to output the final state
of this turing machine after an
exponentially
many steps um and
you want to get this final state in an
interactive way
uh you know by interacting with the
approver
so you can reduce to um i p equals p
space
by simply just treating each bit of this
final state s
as the answer to a decision problem for
example is the jth bit
of this final state equal to one or not
and you can just summon for each of
these output bits
the ip equals p space protocol to
determine what the right bit should be
so you can
find the final state bit by bit all
right so that's pretty
straightforward
in contrast you know this motivating
task that we
have at the beginning you know this
quantum state synthesis problem seems
more difficult
right so the verifier is trying to
verify the construction of
um a very complicated fragile object
it's complicated because to classically
describe this object that it wants to
get
out at the end um you know it's the
description involves two to the n
complex amplitudes right um and
furthermore it you want this
object in quantum form and you want to
ensure
somehow that for example um this this
state and qubit state that you have in
your hands is not
entangled with anything else um you know
it's really has the right amplitudes and
all the right phases
um and and you know this this uh it's
it's not quite clear our priority how
one might
try to do this
so the main results uh that
we show is that uh
you know expressed in in some kind of um
in terms of what i call state quantum
state complexity classes
is that state p space is contained in
state qip
so state p space think of it as the
state complexity analog
of p space and state qip is the state
complexity analog of
qoip
and let me unwrap uh you know what this
really means and give a little more
detail about
what this result is saying
so so here's uh the theorem
so here in order to kind of make this
well defined we actually have to talk
about not just
synthesizing a single state but rather
an infinite family states and that way
we can meaningfully talk about
asymptotics and
complexity so let's say you walk up with
what i call a
space uniform family of quantum states
okay
so these states psi n are they're
indexed by the integers
psi n is a state on n qubits
for each n there exists
an interactive state synthesis protocol
uh satisfying the the completeness
property such that
where the honest proverb is accepted
with probability one
and condition on output on acceptance
which which always happens the output
state is going to be exponentially close
to the ideal target state
psi n now the soundness property is
if approver is accepted with even
slightly above
exponentially small probability then
the output state conditioned on
accepting
is going to be inverse polynomial close
to
the target state cyan
so that's the main theorem we prove
about
interactive state synthesis um
before i go on are there any questions
henry could you say a little bit about
how
you showed the uh
decision to search hardness in the qma
maybe that
could be a little illuminating oh
um
[Music]
yeah so i won't be able to say too much
about it i mean essentially
um um
so basically the the the oracle just
hides
uh a random encuba state like a har
random and cubist state and
the q the qma oracle problem in that
case
is um uh you want to distinguish between
whether the oracle hides
uh some state or it's just acts as the
identity so
um the witness in that case is uh going
to be
um you know either the random state if
that's what the oracle is hiding or
uh if that's the uh yes instance and
and so intuitively you know if you want
to actually prepare this quantum state
you have to make an exponential number
of queries to
[Music]
this quantum oracle and having the
ability to
decide yes or no answers to the qma
questions
even though these are qma oracle
questions
intuitively doesn't help you locate or
construct this state
so that's kind of the the short summary
of it
and someone just you know not so
satisfying because you know
it's uh you you have a quantum oracle
and it's
hiding a horror random state and there's
no notion of um
locality uh in some sense um so you know
it's not clear how much this is saying
about like the local hamiltonians
problem
and the ability to prepare ground states
but it's at least some kind of
evidence that it's hard
[Music]
okay so uh actually i should probably
i didn't explain what i meant by space
uniform you you probably can guess but
but let me um
sort of uh explain that so um
so let's talk a little bit about state
complexity classes
so a family of quantum states so you
have an
uh you know sequence of states psi one
psi two
so on uh we say that it's space uniform
if there's a uniform family of quantum
circuits
uh cn and these circuits uh
can be exponentially large but they are
just restricted to
using polynomial space
and each of these states in the family
can be constructed
um by uh from uh uh the circuit applied
to the all zero state
um so so that's what i mean by space
uniform um and it really just means that
um
there's sort of like one quantum
polynomial space turing machine that
that generates each of these states
so uh state p space
is defined to be it's the class of all
state space uniform families of quantum
states
and state qip is going to be the class
of all state families
that admit interactive state synthesis
protocols
and so since both of these classes are
classes of state families we can talk
about inclusions
and compare them uh with each other and
uh and our main theorem like i mentioned
was is the conclusion that
um any all space uniform uh families of
quantum states
admit interactive states and business
protocols
so here um you know like i mentioned
before
uh state peace base and state qip are
what i call
state complexity classes um we're
talking about
families of quantum states rather than
families and languages you know which
are just sets of strings
and here's kind of a more general
question that
i think is really interesting is you
know you can define all sorts of
state complexity classes
and you can ask well what is the
landscape of state complexity theory
look like and how does it relate to our
typical complexity theory where we just
talk about
decision languages
all right so uh in the last part of
you know the last 10 minutes or so i'll
sort of explain
how we interactively synthesize a state
so here's the warm-up we're first going
to talk about an
interactive state synthesis protocol
where the verifier interacts with a
trusted prover
in other words an oracle um
and uh
the scott aaronshin showed a few years
ago
um uh or at least you know this is sort
of the only reference i could find
is that in this setting you
there's a pretty easy way of you know
synthesizing any quantum state
so there's a polynomial size quantum
circuit v
such that for all n cubist states psi
there's a classical oracle a that
depends on the state psi
such that the quantum circuit you know
makes a polynomial number of queries to
the oracle
and it can synthesize psi up to
exponentially small
error
how does this protocol work well the
basic idea is that
the algorithm v is going to build the
state psi cubit by qubit
and it's going to use a classical oracle
at each step to compute
something called conditional amplitudes
of psi in superposition
what are conditional amplitudes well
the easiest way is to describe it kind
of recursively so
let's say you take your state psi this
target state
i'm going to write it as the following
so i'm going to pull out the first qubit
and you know write it in this way so
alpha 0 and alpha 1 are complex numbers
psi 0 and psi 1 are going to be n minus
1 qubit states
so we can think of psi zero as being uh
the state of you know the the n minus
one qubits
um conditioned on the first qubit being
zero
and similarly psi one is is the state uh
the residual state condition on the
first qubit being one
uh and then you can sort of recurse on
psi zero and psi one to
to compute these these other um uh
complex numbers uh
so you know for let's say b is equal to
zero
then alpha zero zero and alpha one one
are defined in analogous ways
um and and you can sort of continue
splitting off these states
in these this way and the these these
complex numbers that you get out are
conditional amplitudes
another way of thinking about it is that
if you multiply the conditional
amplitudes together then you recover the
the amplitudes of the
the original state side
all right so so here's the protocol
the verifier is going to ask the oracle
to compute uh the first two conditional
amplitudes so these are the alpha zero
and alpha one that we saw earlier
since the oracle is trusted the verifier
knows that these numbers are
really what they're supposed to be the
verifier is going to prepare a one cubit
state
so it's going to be alpha zero ket zero
plus alpha one ket one
um it has this one qubit and then it's
going to
uncompute uh these conditional
amplitudes alpha zero and alpha one
so it'll just perform the reverse of the
oracle call
now controlled on this one cubit state
controlled on it being in some classical
basis state b
the verifier is going to recursively
invoke the same protocol but for the
the smaller n minus one qubit states so
it's then going to
um construct uh in superposition
uh you know condition on the first qubit
being zero it's then going to construct
psi zero
and then condition on one is going to
construct psi one and by definition
if it does this successfully then it is
really going to construct
sign
right henry yeah the question in the
chat by abhinav deshpande
um he's asking to understand the state
classes better
would state qma be the set of accepting
witnesses for a qma computation
oh uh that's a good so i actually
haven't thought of
how you define state qma but that seems
like a very reasonable
um definition yeah
and i have a question about um what
you're saying right now
um so in general this action that the
prover does of telling you like the
amplitudes after you know sort of
setting a prefix to what the
first part of state that should be
something that is outside of qma right
because otherwise you would have the
decision to search
um search your decision
yeah i mean well i guess again qma
refers to uh
decision problems right um i guess
yeah uh i guess that's kind of related
to what sandy was mentioning yesterday
i guess you can yeah but i guess yeah
the moral is that
computing these these amplitudes seems
to be more difficult than qma in
in in any sense that one could consider
okay yeah okay good yeah or it's not
clear how to how to do it in in
qma yeah
um yeah so so you know so this is the
the protocol with the trusted prover uh
and if you unroll this recursion
you know what you see is that um the
queries that the verifier is making to
the oracle is really just to get these
conditional amplitudes
all right so um
cool so you know our goal is to remove
this trusted uh
trust assumption and so the the
intermediate
result is um well we know something
special about the states that we want to
synthesize
they come from a space uniform family
and uh it turns out that the conditional
amplitudes of
states from space uniform families are
actually computable
at least within some small exponentially
exponential error it's computable in p
space classical p space
there's a polynomial space classical
turing machine that
on input n and given a
particular conditional amplitude to
compute it will compute it for you
so that that gives us an idea well let's
let's take this
protocol um with a trusted prover
and instead of trusting it why don't we
replace
this part right
with uh an interactive protocol to
compute these conditional amplitudes
so here let's leverage the fact that qip
is equal to p space
to ensure that we actually get these
conditional amplitudes correctly
henry sorry there's another question
couple questions actually about the
uncompute
people are confused how this happens
uh in the trusted protocol yeah this
step through
the verifier uncomputes alpha zero alpha
one
um yeah so uh
so here uh the oracle call is just a
classical oracle call so there's
you know um all this is happening
coherently so conditioned on
the the prefix of the state um it's
going to
send the prefix to the oracle and the
oracle will
return in a separate register it will
xor
the conditional amplitudes in the you
know it's just like the standard
mono model of uh calling in oracle and
quantum algorithms
and this on compute is just to uh
perform the inverse of that
uh and in this case i guess you can just
call the oracle again and it will just
undo the xor of the conditional
amplitudes and you've erased
the classical information about the
amplitudes
so so in the trusted oracle setting this
is pretty straightforward
that that's not so tricky
it gets trickier when we have an
untrusted oracle or untrusted prover
right so we have this idea of uh
you know to compute these conditional
amplitudes let's run the qip equals
p-space protocol
um and you know hopefully everything
should work out
right so um so this is the
uh the attempt you know we replace this
first step with running qip equals
pspace to compute
alpha zero alpha one we do everything as
before
in the uncomputation step one might
imagine that let's try to run the
qyp equals pspace protocol in reverse
all right so there's some problems with
this
um and the problem is that since the
prover is untrusted you know it's it can
be adversarial and it knows we're trying
to compute these
uh these amplitudes and those we're
trying to uh construct this state
so it might try to uh adversarially
perform some quantum attacks on the
protocol
and get us to accept and generate a
state that's different
from our target state
what we've done you know now that we
have this qip equals p space protocol
embedded inside our state synthesis
protocol
the soundness of this implies that the
prover can never
uh get the verifier to accept
wrong conditional amplitude so at least
classically
the the alpha zero and alpha one will be
correct
right because that's what q equals p
space guarantees us
and so in some sense i'll say that this
qip equals speed space defends against
classical attacks
but a malicious prover can at least in
this protocol as described can
cheat by mounting quantum attacks so
what's an example of a quantum attack
it can perform something called an
entanglement attack so for example
during the qip equals p-space portion of
the protocol
um which is just sending um
let's say classical messages back and
forth um
uh between the verifier and the approver
the approver can entangle its private
workspace with the messages
and at the end of the the the protocol
the final state of the verifier improver
could look like the following
um you know the verifiers workspace
could at least
you know look like what it's supposed to
um you know if psi is alpha x
kept x then then the verifies workspace
could look like this but then
the x part could be entangled with the
prover's workspace
i mean after all the the prover is
getting
what prefix we're conditioning on to to
generate the
to compute the conditional amplitudes so
so knows what x is
um and this would be bad because when
the verifier outputs this register this
is actually going to decode here and
you're going to get just a a
probabilistic mixture of
x's and it won't you know won't be
coherent
um so that's bad um
and uh you know there's sort of kind of
like an uh
a subtler version of the entanglement
attack you know maybe the prover isn't
entangled but
it could introduce spurious phases which
ruin your state
so um i've seen the remaining
zero minutes i have um uh
i'll i'll just quickly say that we can
fix these problems by introducing
um genuinely quantum we can introduce
quantum tests to
to detect these types of attacks
um and and roughly the the idea is that
the the verifier is going to maintain
the invariant as it's building the state
qubit by qubit
it's actually going to have two copies
of the state so um
uh you know at the j step you know we
assume that
as long as the verifier hasn't rejected
so far it's going to have two copies of
this intermediate state psi j okay
and um it's it's going to try to um
at each round it's always it's either
going to
uh grow the state by one qubit or it's
going to perform a test round
and the the prover won't know until it's
too late
whether it's a test round or a grow
round
in if it's a grow round then it'll do
what it did before it will run the
qip equals pspace protocol to grow it by
one uh you know this first copy by one
qubit
but if it's a test round then it'll run
qip equals p space
but then it won't actually introduce an
extra qubit it'll just try to perform
the reverse
and if the the prover is being malicious
then this state could get corrupted
but what the verifier is going to do is
it's going to perform a swap test
between these two copies
so we're assuming that this second copy
is is
um the true uh like a legitimate
valid state so it can test the these two
copies
and uh if the test passes what the
verifier can deduce is that the prover
actually didn't do anything fishy in the
qip equals p space portion of the
protocol
which means that in the grow step
actually
you go from j to j plus one uh in
in the correct fashion and once that
happens
then um the uh the verifier will
will just ask the approver to give it a
second copy
of the j plus first state and it'll do
another swap test to make sure that
they're the same
uh and and regardless of whether we're
doing a test round or a grow round
we maintain the invariant that we have
two copies of of the correct
intermediate state
okay so um i'm out of time but maybe
i'll i'll just
uh quickly mention that i think
the most interesting part of this work
is that there's just a ton of
open interesting open problems to think
about
so we showed that state
space is contained in state qip but we
don't actually know how to prove the
reverse it'd be really nice if we can
and show that state p space is equal to
state qip but we don't
know if that's true so so that's an open
question um
you know are there uh cryptographic
applications of interactive state
synthesis
um you know as a sort of a
an elaboration on that like is you know
it'd be really cool if there was like a
an interesting notion of zero knowledge
state synthesis like what would that
mean and can we achieve that
um what kinds of states can we construct
with
multiple approvers presumably we can
construct more complicated types of
states
and then you know finally more generally
what does a you know what does quantum
state complexity theory look like
um okay so so i'll stop here um
oops and uh you know unfortunately i
didn't get a chance to talk about
unitary synthesis
but would be happy to talk about that
offline
thank you okay thank you very much henry
so we have time for questions now
can i ask a question henry uh
so uh you know
a couple of things i i didn't i didn't
quite follow your tests
and uh generic protocol and then i had a
question on the previous slide
oh yeah what what's the you know what's
an upper bound do you have an upper
bound on the
uh this inclusion that you gave that you
unsure oh an upper bound on state qip
yeah um whether there's any upper bound
at all
yeah um
it's not 100 clear to me because um you
know you
uh you might try to brute force over all
um
prover strategies and
it's it's not obvious off the top of my
head whether
you know there's any demand again
there's any dimension
upper bound on the optimal
quantum prover strategy
[Music]
you know it and i should mention that
actually you know even proving
qip equals p space the decision version
i think the hard part was again showing
um an upper bound on on qip like
eventually they showed that there's an
stp that characterizes it but
i'm not sure if there's a there's an
obvious upper bound
perhaps a basic question i could ask is
what is the power
required for the honest prover do they
have to be in just p
space is the protocol you stated
oh um for the honest prover uh yeah
p space because they have to be able to
compute conditional amplitudes
and p space and not sharp
uh right that's because these are um
space uniform
states so they can encode piece space
complete problems
and what if what if they were uniform
if they were sharp p uniform
um i think it still might be p space
because we're using they
they have to compute these sum checks um
for uh
um oh i see
i'm not i'm not 100 sure i i think it
still might be p space because
uh you know they have to solve the sum
check protocol right so
um
oh but i i guess yeah actually then then
it might be
sharp p yeah because yeah
i guess my question then is is state qip
contained in a
in in the class where you um talk to a
trusted p space prover or like have a p
space oracle
um and does it would that help with your
first question
so using the fact that maybe it's easier
to bound
just a b to b uh
machine that has access to a p space
oracle maybe that's something that's
easier to bound
um so what is
[Music]
so what's the model like there's no
completeness and soundness anymore right
um
oh so in that model i i mean i guess you
know what what scott showed was is that
actually
all states can be constructed in that
model
right so um even you know uncomputable
states
whatever that means um
[Music]
yeah so so that one contains everything
and
as far as state complexity goes
so can i ask a question
so uh it seems that okay this particle
only works when you have a pure state
right so
can you say something about mixed states
oh yeah that's a great question i don't
know um i mean
i thought about um you know maybe you
can try to construct like a purification
but uh but it's but you know it's not
clear like suppose that you had a space
uniform family of mixed states
does that imply that the purifications
are space uniform that's like totally
not clear to me
do you know what the status of the
classical analogue of this question is
we are trying to construct the
probability distribution oh that one is
um
right so that one is uh uh
okay so uh class classical distribution
piece space is contained in classical
distribution
ip uh for the reverse direction
um um
you mean like an upper bound on on on
the ip
uh like constructing a uh like sampling
from a distribution
i'm not sure yeah i imagine the upper
bound would
would also be p space but i haven't
thought about it
so can i connect the kiosk you know you
had this
uh test and grow protocol so i wasn't
clear but i think i missed something
about it
so uh so are you assuming that the
prover sort of
uh gives you society on demand and then
then you check whether the next you know
and then you
do checks on it in terms of whether
where they grew properly and then
swapping is otherwise the two tests
roughly yeah so um in the test round we
don't actually
um uh grow uh grow the first state
but instead we just run qip equals p
space
forwards and then backwards and we test
whether
um these uh these two states are the
same
we're we're assuming this like but sort
of by induction that the second state is
is honest in the grow round
uh we we do grow this state by one qubit
and then what we just discard this
second copy and ask the prover for
psi j plus one sorry how do you get the
inductive
you know how since you're asking for
this state
what gives you the guarantee that it was
it was correct to begin with
oh i see because um because of the test
round
if that passes with high probability
then we know that in the grow round
this first register state is grown
correctly um
right but if you already know that why
do you need the second copy then
oh um because for the in the next step
we're going to again do a test or grow
and you need the second copy to ensure
that the test
round has the right guarantees
um so so again like uh what's happening
in the test round we're not actually
going to grow the state
we're just going to run we're going to
make the prover think we're growing
so we're going to pretend we're growing
this first register
but we're not but we just want to make
sure that
the approver hasn't done anything
malicious to to the first copy
so so that's why we need inductively why
we need the second
copy to uh to test it again
does it only does it tell you that you
have some symmetric subspace so what
what what is it eventually
what you eventually get from it in
general yeah that's what the
swap test promises you but um since we
have this
uh invariant or this inductive
assumption that
the the state of these two registers are
the tensor product of pure states then
the swap test will really ensure that
we really have two copies of the same
pure state
okay so any other question
so there is one in the uh fna
is a prepping version of this available
online
uh the the oh yeah so
um this this should come on the archive
uh hopefully soon
um yeah so so this uh this will be
out soon okay so we have one minute left
so do you want to say something fast
about the synthesizing unitaries
oh yeah um so
this um i'll say
much one thing okay so what is the the
task of synthesizing unitaries
um uh here you're given a description of
an exponentially long circuit uh but
you're
but then you're also given a an input
state in quantum form so you'll only get
one copy of it
or maybe a small number of copies
depending on what model you consider
and you uh so call that input state
phi you want to synthesize
this the circuit c applied to phi
so it seems very similar but now the
difference is
um you no longer as the verifier no
longer has even an implicit
classical description of the output
state
and you want to generate this output
state and the question is can you do it
interactively and this seems very uh
much more difficult and we kind of have
a
we don't have a similar result like this
one what we can show is that if your
unitary
um has an assumption on it which is that
it acts non-trivially
on a subspace of only polynomial
dimension right so out of two to the n
dimensions and only acts non-trivial on
a subspace of dimension poly n then we
can actually do this
um unitary synthesis solve this unitary
synthesis problem
um but uh how do you go beyond
polynomial dimension
that that's an open question so
okay great well thanks a lot uh henry
yeah thank you
next speaker is andrea colo
angelo from uc